[Music]
welcome to year and review the show
where we break down a year to bring you
some of the most notable moments in TV
and film month by month and off we go
today for a visit to 2012 it was a
pretty big year the Olympics were held
in London the NBA was held in a state of
Lin sanity and Gangam Style dance offs
were held on dance floors everywhere of
course it was also a big year for Te and
movies The Avengers and The Dark Knight
faced off at the box office Disney
bought lucas films and put episode 7 in
motion Merl won her third Oscar and
flesh eting zombies were setting cable
TV ratings records there was also the
release of 50 Shades of Gray which we
won't be talking about too much but it's
cool cuz plenty of people still are
talking about that one wink wink nudge
nudge speaking of which go ahead and
strap yourself in cuz we're heading to
the year 2012 right now on year in revie
[Music]
view stop volunteer I
volunteer I volunteer as
tribute I believe we have a volunteer
opening in March was The Hunger Games
based on the 2008 novel of the same name
written by Suzanne Collins who also
co-wrote the screenplay the film takes
place in a dystopian post-apocalyptic
future where Katniss everine played by
Jennifer Lawrence takes her younger
sister's place in a nationally televised
ultimate fight to the death called The
Hunger Games the movie was a huge hit at
the box office with nearly $695 million
earned worldwide good enough for ninth
best in
thank you for your
consideration that was also good enough
to make three more in the series
Catching Fire mocking J part 1 and
mocking J part two released in each of
the following 3 years through 2015 all
of which are also fresh on the Tomato
Meter and were also big money makers
critics say thrilling and superbly acted
the Hunger Games captures the dramatic
violence raw emotion and ambicious scope
of its source
[Music]
novel The Fish rots from the
head what your boys in the Secret
Service they're taking their cues from
you because you're the head of of the
fish Reckless negligent selfish you're
letting things get out of hand and your
boys are following what kind of example
are you setting for the people who work
for you for the country for your son
stirring things up in April was the
premiere of ABC's hit series Scandal
from Creator Shonda Rimes best known for
Gray's Anatomy at the time this one
Stars krie Washington as Olivia Pope a
former media consultant to the president
who moves on to start her own crisis
manag firm but her lingering pass gets
her caught up in plenty of drama along
the way you didn't make it to that
dinner tonight because I didn't want to
go why would I Fitz so I could sit in
the corner with the other Housewives and
force myself to watch you run with the
big dogs across the room guess what I am
a big dog so I didn't want to go I knew
this was going to happen I knew when I
moved you in here the series ran for
seven fresh Seasons six of them
certified fresh and even featured a
crossover episode with another Shonda
show for which that show's star Viola
Davis was nominated for an Emmy for
Outstanding guest actress I don't know
there's no Rhymes or Reason to it get it
Scandal helped make Carrie Washington a
household name in a role that was
actually partially based on a former
press aid for George HW Bush named Judy
Smith who was a co-executive producer on
the show got to love it critics say
Scandal is a soapy show about work and
love that's over the top but never
boring I've got a purple on my chest but
the one that beats inside of me is red
white and blue no he didn't a common B
moment and that's why this is the
greatest country on earth I am going to
throw up a leg and then I'm going to
take that leg and I'm going to beat
Scott to death with it Scott April also
brought us a different kind of look at
politics and one that would eventually
become oddly accurate with the premiere
of HBO's vep and what could very well be
considered a second career defining role
after Seinfeld Julia Louie dfus stars as
Selena Meyer who during the show's run
goes from vice president to president to
nothing back to president are you not
going to say
anything Jesus Dan did your boyfriend
know anything about this I was trying to
use Jonah for intelligence that's like
trying to use a quason as aing dildo I
thought no no no let me be more clear it
doesn't do the job and it makes a
mess beep ran for seven straight
certified fresh seasons and received
Emmy Noms for outstanding comedy series
in all of those years winning the award
three times in other words it's one of
the funniest shows on TV which is not
only a credit to the improvisation
abilities of Julia Louie dfus who won a
record six consecutive Emmys but also
her Stellar Supporting Cast that
includes Tony hail Anna schumy Gary Cole
and Matt Walsh to name a few critics say
the jokes are funny and Julia Louie
driis is great in the lead but vep is
still working to find its
voice Dr
Banner now might be a really good time
for you to get angry that's my secret
cat I'm always
angry assembling in May of 2012 was
Marvel's The Avengers directed and
co-written by Jos Weeden this one brings
together Ironman Hulk Captain America
Thor the Black Widow and Hawkeye to take
on Thor's evil brother Loki who is
looking to invade Earth and become king
Weeden who was once considered to direct
the X-Men film in 2000 said that this
movie was strongly influenced by the
early 196s Avengers Comics you are all
of you beneath me I am a god you dull
creature
and I will not be bullied by
[Applause]
that puny
[Music]
God but he said it could have looked a
bit different considering Ant-Man and
wasp were cut from The Script due to too
many characters and a more extensive
backstory for Hawkeye was left on The
Cutting Room floor The Avengers grossed
over 1 .5 billion worldwide and was the
highest grossing film of 2012 not to
mention it was the first Marvel
production to hit the b word you know
billion critics say thanks to a script
that emphasizes its Hero's humanity and
a wealth of superpowered set pieces The
Avengers lives up to its hype and raises
the bar for Marvel at the
[Music]
movies touch
is that too the law says that you cannot
touch but I think I see a lot of law
Breakers up in this house dancing its
way into theaters in June was Magic Mike
directed by Steven Soderberg and
starring Channing Tatum Matthew
mcconahay and Alex pedford among others
the film which was Loosely based on
Tatum's history as an 18-year-old male
stripper follows a veteran dancer played
by Tatum who takes a young newcomer
played by Petty under his wing and shows
him the ropes Mikey Mikey Mikey I just
came off an idea man an idea an idea
give me something you go out then give
me something man I'm not hitting the
floor come
on you want me to come up something yeah
[Applause]
man I hope you can dance you're still
over me come
[Applause]
on the certified fresh Dance Flick was a
surprise hit at the box office I mean
was it a surprise though pulling in over
160 $7 million worldwide against a
measly $7 million budget and with that
success came more Magic mik movies with
less clothing including XXL released in
2015 and Magic Mike's last dance in 2023
critics say Magic Mike's sensitive
Direction smart screenplay and strong
performances allow audiences to have
their beef cake and eat it
too
[Music]
swinging into theaters over the July 4th
holiday weekend in 2012 was The Amazing
Spider-Man it was directed by Mark Webb
and a accomplished music video director
who made his feature film debut with 500
Days of Summer in 2009 this movie shares
the title of the character's longest
running comic book series and is the
fourth theatrical Spider-Man Film SL
reboot of the series following Sam ry's
Trilogy from 2002 to 2007 this time
around Andrew Garfield steps into the
role of Peter Parker chasing bad guys
and chasing his Crush Gwen Stacy played
by Emma
Stone
I'm going to throw you out the window
now gurfield admitted to shedding tears
the first time he wore the Spider-Man
costume and hey who can blame him
speaking speak of that tear inducing
suit contained one major new theatrical
design included from the comics
artificial web shooters this the first
of two The Amazing Spider-Man films
became the 12th highest grossing film of
the year and was followed by a sequel in
2014 and of course Garfield returned
again in the 2022 MCU film Spider-Man no
way home oh spoilers critics say a
well-chosen cast and sure-handed
Direction allowed The Amazing Spider-Man
to Thrill despite revisiting many of the
same plot points from 2002
Spider-Man oh you think darkness is your
ally you merely adopted the
dark I was born in
it molded by
it I didn't see the light until I was
already a man by then it was nothing to
me but
blinding emerging in July of 2012 12 was
The Dark Knight Rises directed and
co-written by Christopher Nolan and
marking the final installment in his
Dark Knight trilogy the film takes place
8 years after the event of 2008's The
Dark Knight and introduces the villains
Bane played by Tom Hardy and an
Hathaway's Catwoman two big reasons why
Batman is forced out of Exile and into
battle Nolan who was hesitant to return
for a third ultimately Drew inspiration
from Bane's comic book debut in 1993
along with the 198 six series The Dark
Knight Returns and the 1999 story line
called No Man's
Land so you came back to die with your
city
no I came back to stop
you the result is what is considered to
be one of the best superhero films and
best sequels ever The Dark Knight Rises
grossed over $1 billion worldwide making
it the second movie in the Batman film
series to earn $1 billion and the
seventh highest grossing film ever at
the time critics say The Dark Knight
Rises is an ambitious thoughtful and
potent action film that concludes
Christopher Nolan's franchise in
spectacular
[Music]
fashion please help my son how long's it
been under 3 minutes maybe more let's
get that straight R for the Ed of right
now exactly where did he fall in right
here he came up for a second then he he
went right back down
[Music]
again keep feeding me line until I hit
bottom then allow six more feet every
time I tug twice all right when I tug
three times I've got the kids as the
calendar turned to fall in 2012 things
were just heating up on TV with the
premiere of NBC's Chicago Fire in
October the series which began its 11th
season in the fall of 2022 follows the
lives of firefighters and rescue
Personnel for the fictional Chicago
Firehouse 51 with stars Jesse Spencer
and Taylor Kenny leading the way there's
a guy still inside us H Chief give me
one more minute to go back in there no
it's over no more minutes he could be
alive just give me one more minute I
know I can get to him I know not going
anywhere this building's about to
enough Chicago Fire ended up being the
first installment in Executive Producer
Dick Wolf's Chicago franchise which also
included Chicago PD Chicago Med and the
Very short-lived Chicago Justice the
long running Series has been nominated
for multiple People's Choice Awards for
favorite network TV drama and has
maintained a strong audience score on
Rotten Tomatoes for its entire run
critics say Chicago Fire has an
attractive cast and some exciting
rescues but it breaks little new ground
in terms of plotting or characterization
you think this is more plausible than
teachers yes we do one there are no more
foreign teachers in Iran and we think
everybody knows Hollywood people and
everybody knows they'd shoot in stalling
grab with Paul pot directing if it would
sell
tickets there are only bad options it's
about finding the best
one you don't have a better bad idea
than this this is the best bad idea we
have sir by far also arriving in October
was the film Argo directed by Ben
Affleck and partially adapted from the
1999 Memoir The Master of Disguise by
CIA operative Tony Mendes speaking of
which affle also co-stars in this one as
Mendes who's posed as a Hollywood
producer in order to help rescue six
Americans from Iran in
1979 my god Ra to number one full back
look I need police I need police right
now you understand me right now
God there is
a burn everything burn it now all right
burn everything all the files file
cabinet affle said the production was
given unparalleled access to CIA
headquarters thanks to Mendes and in
order to give things more of that 1970s
Vibe Affleck Shot the movie on regular
35mm film and also basically begged the
band Led Zeppelin to use their song When
the Levy Breaks the certified fresh Argo
went on to become the first film in 23
years to win the Academy Award for best
picture without being nominated for best
director sorry Ben you did good though
man critics say tense exciting and often
Darkly comic Argo recreates a historic
event with Vivid attention to detail and
finally rot
[Music]
characters well Hazard I can do more
damage on my laptop sitting in my
pajamas before my first cup of O gry
than you can do in a year in the field
oh so what do you need
me every now and then a trigger has to
be
pulled or not
pulled it's hard to know wi in your
pajamas
Q7 martinis were being shaken in
November of 2012 with the arrival of
Skyfall in theaters the 25th overall
James Bond film Daniel Craig once again
stepped into the role of James Bond
doing so for the third of what would be
five total times spoilers in this film
he has to track down a threat after MI6
comes under attack and things get rather
personal for him along the way Skyfall
became the highest grossing James Bond
film and the first to gross over $1
billion wowza bond this isn't an escape
this was years in the planning he wanted
us to capture him he wanted us to access
his computer it was all planned blowing
up HQ and the emergency protocols
knowing we'd Retreat down here I got all
that it's what he's got planned next
that worries me it also won several
accolades including two Academy Awards
two bafta Awards and two Grammy Awards
and let's not forget when Daniel Craig
appeared as James Bond escorting Queen
Elizabeth II to London's 2012 Olympic
Games as seen during a video played at
the opening ceremony critics say Sam
mandz brings Bond surging back with a
smart sexy riveting action thriller that
qualifies as one of the best7 films to
[Music]
date
what
the stupid fing book another movie that
hit theaters in November of 2012 was
silver Ling's Playbook written and
directed by David O Russell this movie
stars Bradley Cooper is a man with
bipolar disorder who after losing his
job and wife and spending time in a
mental institution turns to a young
Widow named Tiffany played by Jennifer
Lawrence for help what was he saying no
he's saying you're being rude how am I
being rude you know you know come on
look sometimes it's okay with girls like
this they want to have fun and sometimes
it's not because they got a broken wing
and they're hurt and they're an easy
target in this case this particular case
I think that that Wing is being fixed my
friend and you got to make sure it gets
mended and you're getting in the way of
that right now okay because she's
sensitive and she's smart she's artistic
this is a great girl and you got to be
respectful to that come on let me walk
you down to your car you're a better guy
than this O Russell said he was drawn to
the story because of the family
relationships and a connection he felt
to his own son and that he rewrote the
script roughly 20 times silver Ling's
Playbook was nominated for eight Oscars
total including becoming the first film
since 1981 to have a nomination in all
four acting categories that included
Cooper Robert dairo Jackie Weaver and
Lawrence the latter of which had the
only win for the film and became the
second youngest best actress winner ever
at the time critics say Silver Linings
Playbook walks a tricky thematic tight
RPP but David O Russell's sensitive
Direction and some sharp work from a
talented cast gives it true
balance opening around Thanksgiving
fittingly was life a pie directed and
produced by Ang Lee and based on Yan
Martell's 2008 novel of the same name
the film revolves around two shipwreck
survivors a 16-year-old Indian boy named
pip Patel played by shaj Sharma and a
mean bangal tiger named Richard
[Music]
Parker
various directors like ight Shyamalan
and Alfonso Kiran were involved at
different times before Ang Le was
brought on board but that's nothing
compared to the roughly 3,000 young men
who auditioned for the lead role before
the 17-year-old newcomer Sharma got the
gig the certified Fresh Life of Pi
sailed to success at the box office and
Beyond as in it was nominated for 11
Oscars including best picture and best
adapted screenplay and won four
including best director for Lee but
seriously who's hungry for pie now
critics say a 3D adaptation of a
supposedly unfilmable book Ang Le's life
of pie achieves the near impossible it's
an astonishing technical achievement
that's also emotionally
rewarding you mind telling me what the
hell you doing I confirmed that P is at
Candyland you sure it's her it didn't
call her by name but she's a young lady
Whit marks on her back and speaks German
now while it's not wise to assume in
this instance I think it's pretty safe
and finally as a nice bloody I mean
shiny gift to open on Christmas Day in
2012 was D Jango unchain from writer and
director Quinton Tarantino the film
stars Jamie Fox as a freed slave who is
out to rescue his wife from a nasty
Plantation owner played by Leonardo
DiCaprio so we enlist the help of a
German Bounty Hunter played by Kristoff
w
now BR
boy I will admit you are pretty
clever but if I took this Hammer
here and I bashed in your scull
it you would have the same three
dimples in the same
place as old
Ben hey lay your palm flat on that
tabletop Tarantino actually wrote go
with Will Smith in mind but the actor
ultimately passed on the project which
paved the way for Fox and the Stacked
cast he's a part of also includes names
like kry Washington Samuel L Jackson
Walton gogins and Don Johnson ultimately
though Kristoff Walt stole the show
winning bafta Golden Globe and Academy
Awards for Best Supporting Actor the
latter went along with Tarantino's Oscar
win for best adapted screenplay making
up the film's two wins of five
nominations critics say bold bloody and
stylistically daring D Jango one change
is another incendiary Masterpiece from
Quinton Tarantino well there you have it
2012 in a nutshell and by nutshell I
mean a very well- written and produced
episode of year in review what a cool
year for Big Time franchises and shows
about fire stations what was your
favorite movie or show from the 12 let
us know thanks for checking out year
review we'll see you next
time